herzlich willkommen zum Wohnungsprojekt
dem Projekt in dem ich eine Wohnung
kaufe sie rausreiße renoviere und nach
meinen und euren Träumen Umbau die Wände
sind fertig gestrichen das bedeutet wir
werden in dieser Folge endlich den Boden
verlegen und unserem Mars angefertigte
Einbaulösung installieren vermutlich der
größte Fortschritt den wir je zusammen
in einem Video hatten sieben volle
Arbeitstage ich wünsche euch viel Spaß
Arbeitstag Nummer eins Boden vorbereiten
wenn der so
fliegt der logischerweise
damit der Parkett hier rein kann der
Estrich der hier drin ist bestehen
gerade auf dem Estrich das ist quasi die
Schicht die kommt bevor der Boden drauf
kommt die muss komplett gerade sein
damit wir hier echten wirklichen
Echtholz Parkett reinballern können und
genau darum kümmern wir uns jetzt denn
in den nächsten Tagen geht es direkt
schon mit dem Parkett weiter da habe ich
gerade Leute für organisiert und wir
probieren den jetzt die Arbeit einfach
zu machen wie es geht und haben dafür
diese Riesen Schleifmaschine und genau
das machen wir jetzt
[Musik]
mit ein bisschen Übung hat es dann
tatsächlich ganz gut funktioniert
zumindest das bodenschleifen
Alter genau das hat mir jetzt gerade
noch gefehlt
[Musik]
ich weiß wirklich nicht was ich sagen
soll einfach nur richtig krass aus ich
bin mega happy das ist endlich nicht
mehr Abriss sondern es wird wieder
aufgebaut
Tag Nummer zwei Anlieferung der heißen
waren sie sind da
servus Dave moin freut mich moin
[Musik]
ja
aber was habe ich mir eigentlich liefern
lassen also du hast 2,5 mm Nutzschicht
das heißt quasi es ist kein massives
Brett sondern einen dreischichtpaket hat
eigentlich so den Vorteil so zum
Hintergrund Holz ist immer ein weicher
Werkstoff hier dicker das Holz und so
tiefer kann es sich einkehren bei
Druckbelastung des Weiteren Matte
lackierte Oberfläche fühlt sich nicht so
schön an wie naturbügelter Boden dafür
aber viel viel pflegeleichter du kannst
den ein bisschen besser wischen ein
bisschen besser saugen der ist ein
bisschen kratz unempfindlicher und so
weiteren sind ziemlich klein und
ziemlich schmal das kann nur eins
bedeuten ich habe mich für
fischkettenparkett entschieden natürlich
für meine Wohnung nur das Beste vom
Besten ja die Jungs von der Holzgalerie
sind extra angereist um es mir
persönlich vorbeizubringen um mir und
euch noch mal genau zu sagen worauf sie
ankommt und dieses Parkett werden wir
dann in den nächsten Tagen professionell
verlegen lassen ist natürlich sehr
wichtig und genau dafür ist auch wichtig
dass wir den Boden vorher noch mal 100%
nivellieren alles was wir am Estrich
jetzt nicht machen wird nachher Probleme
geben sobald der Boden verlegt ist oder
beim Verlegen und ich danke euch
vielmals alle Links von den Jungs sind
in der Videobeschreibung also für jeden
von euch der ein parkettsuche in
irgendeiner Weise Beratung braucht
Millennium seid ihr auf jeden Fall an
der richtigen Adresse ich bedanke mich
vielmals für euch und wir kümmern uns
ums verlegen
ich habe da hier so eine große
Schleifmaschine geholt die hat auch in
den ersten paar Minuten gemacht was sie
wollte und irgendwann habe ich dann
vernünftig hinbekommen
und dann hat das richtig gut
funktioniert aber nicht gut genug als
dass ich hier den Boden wirklich gerade
bekommen hätte und genau deswegen musste
ein extra Tag Arbeit einschieben du
musst den Boden nivellieren also eine
extra Schicht auf dem Boden unter dem
Parkett damit der Parkett auf 100%
gerade im Boden verlegt werden kann und
dadurch auch für immer komplett gerade
bleibt wenn der Boden schief ist wenn
das alles nichts parallel zu diesen
ganzen Arbeiten in der Wohnung kümmern
sich die Schreiner in Ihrer Werkstatt
darum die Einbaulösung schon
vorzubereiten und das nicht nur in den
Tagen wo wir in der Wohnung waren
sondern schon über einen Monat insgesamt
ging der Prozess so wahrscheinlich 3
Monate indem wir uns überlegt haben wie
es aussehen soll und so weiter denn
folgendes soll die Einbaulösung
beinhalten eine Küche ein abstellschrank
ein Kleiderschrank ein versteckten
Eingang ins Bad und vor allem ein Bett
ja das Bett ist in derselben
Einbaulösung integriert wie meine Küche
und ihr werdet auch sehen warum für all
das haben wir natürlich nur super wenig
Platz wir wollen natürlich im Raum so
viel Platz wie möglich haben aber
trotzdem eine vollwertige Küche also
Dings von dem ersten Sketch über
tausende Male messen über Gespräche mit
dem Schreiner bis hin zu fertigen Idee
und dann der Umsetzung die schon
umgesetzt wurde während ich noch ein
Panama war weil erst alles mit obs
Platten vorgebaut wurde es wurde geguckt
ob es passt um kein unnötiges Material
zu verschwenden und das dann wirklich
einmal perfekt genauso wie wir es haben
wollen mit den richtigen Materialien zu
bauen und wenn ich in der wohnungstunde
das Beste vom Besten verbaut dann soll
es natürlich beim Bett auch so sein
deswegen habe ich mich für immer
Matratze entschieden die auch
freundlicherweise dieses Video
unterstützen und erst möglich machen ein
Drittel unseres Lebens verbringen im
Bett ich muss euch also nicht erklären
wie wichtig es für jeden einzelnen von
uns ist gut zu schlafen und zu
regenerieren um einfach auch das Beste
aus unseren Tagen rauszuholen und lange
Zeit habe ich mir darüber keine Gedanken
gemacht bis ich durch eine Empfehlung
von Max selber auf die MA 25
hybrid-matratze umgestiegen bin welche
genau die ist die wir jetzt auf einer
projektwohnung haben die Matratze ist
unheimlich bequem und kein Witz seitdem
ich sie benutze schwitze ich beim
Schlafen nicht mehr was lange Zeit ein
riesen Problem von mir war die Bezüge
sind abnehmbar und somit super easy zu
waschen ihr könnt die Produkte komplett
risikofrei für 100 Tage testen und es
gibt kostenlosen Versand und Abholung
das bedeutet kein unnötiges Schlepp die
Matratze kommt sofort zu euch vor die
Tür direkt nach Hause neben Matratzen
bietet immer noch unheimlich viele
weitere Produkte an also von
Boxspringbetten über Topper Lattenroste
Kissen ist so ziemlich jedes Produkt
dabei dass euer Schlaf verbessert und
bis zum 28.11 bekommt ihr auf alle
Produkte bis zu 33% Rabatt und ihr spart
mit dem Code Dave sogar noch mal 5 % und
Topf also klickt auf den ersten Link in
der Videobeschreibung testet die
Produkte komplett risikofrei und spart
mit dem Code Dave noch mal 5 %. es gibt
wirklich keinen Grund ist nicht
auszuprobieren und euch mit der
Verbesserung eures Schlafes was Gutes zu
tun vielen Dank an immer für die
Unterstützung und euch viel Spaß weiter
mit dem Video Tag Nummer drei
nivellieren schnell anmischen in Lachs
dann geht das über den Boden gegossen
überall verteilt und bis in die Ecken
gezogen gerade bei alten Häusern gibt so
ein bisschen das Problem das gerade zum
Rand sich die Ecken so ein bisschen
Hochziehen der Boden quasi ausgelaufen
wird und das so ein bisschen krumm ist
das darf natürlich nicht sein wenn wir
neuen Boden verlegen wollen das ganze
trocknet über 24 Stunden und somit sind
wir am Tag 4 dem Verlegen des Bodens
hi servus servus von ng Parkett sind
wieder da zweiter Tag nachdem gestern
alles privilegiert wurde wird heute
endlich der Parkett gelegt es sieht
schon richtig richtig gut aus zum Start
zur Vorbereitung muss einmal eine
richtig gerade genaue Linie gelegt
werden von der aus dann der gesamte Raum
gelegt werden kann ich bin leider über
die letzten zwei Tage komplett krank
geworden ich lasse die Kamera hier
stehen ich habe keine Lust die Jungs
anzustecken und fahr schnell wieder nach
Hause in der Wohnung geht's aber
trotzdem weiter und das ist das worum es
geht unheimlich krass zu sehen wie
schnell die Jungs waren innerhalb von
einem Tag haben die den kompletten Boden
da rein geklappt und sehr ärgerlich dass
ich genau an dem Tag krank geworden bin
ich hätte mir gerne was davon abgeschaut
um es vielleicht im nächsten
Umbauprojekt dann selber zu machen das
ist soweit ich finde immer noch krank
aber im Parkett ist schon fertig
aus als könnte man hier wohnen Alter
richtig richtig krass Alter vielen Dank
richtig krank aus
soll ich sagen bin mehr als glücklich
natürlich fehlt noch einiges die
Installation vom Bad und noch ganz viel
mehr und jetzt geht's ab Tag Nummer 5
die Schreiner kommen servus moin alles
klar selbst ja
es ist endlich soweit heute wird die
Wohnung nahezu fertiggestellt mit der
Einbaulösung von der Firma Marenbach
Einbauschrank Küche und das Bett hätte
ich nicht einen verteilen Fehler gemacht
weil das Bad kein Fenster hat haben wir
uns für den größten und besten
Monolithen entschieden der eine
Absaugung hat eine Absaugung braucht
Strom dieser Strom dieses offene Kabel
wurde auch von der Firma Görke hingelegt
ich war allerdings so schlau und habe es
einfach neben das Bett gelegt weil ich
dachte es wäre für eine Steckdose dieses
Kabel sollte aber eigentlich ins Bad
gehen und jetzt liegt das Kabel an der
falschen Stelle das bedeutet ich muss
ein neues Kabel vom Stromkasten bis ins
Bad legen muss dafür die Wand wieder
aufbauen also richtiger heckmeckt mega
die Scheiße komplett mein Fehler und das
alles an dem Tag wo die Firma machen
markieren kommt um das schon einzubauen
also Stress Stress Stress alles wie
immer das hier ist das Kabel dieses
Kabel läuft hinten und müsste eigentlich
auf der anderen Seite im Bad rauskommen
ich habe es neben Bett gelegt hammer
hammer dumm
[Musik]
wunderbar
so das ist die Lösung Kabel wird hier an
das offene Kabel angeschlossen
verschwindet hinter dem Einbauschrank
und geht dann ins Bad hier ist ein Loch
im Bad ist ein Loch und damit haben wir
alle unsere Probleme gelöst wunderbar
Fehler gemacht Fehler behoben so muss
sein
[Musik]
wirklich wirklich unglaublich das hier
sind Teile meiner Mars angefertigten
Küche und natürlich wie alles in dieser
Wohnung das ist komplett overpower diese
komplette Lösung ist maßangefertigt
handgemacht für mich für diese Wohnung
ich weiß das macht alles überhaupt
keinen Sinn aber es ist eben extrem geil
unglaublich mit welcher Präzision die
Jungs das angebracht haben ihren
Millimeter raus dann Millimeter rein und
eigentlich noch verrückter dass Sie das
in Ihrer Werkstatt so präzise gebaut
haben dass es da alles auf eins
funktioniert richtig krass das hat mich
echt aus den Socken gehauen und es sieht
natürlich unheimlich gut aus guckt euch
das mal an genauso habe ich mir das
vorgestellt die stumpf einschlagende Tür
hier sieht unglaublich gut aus hier
neben kommt jetzt der Einbauschrank das
ist der nächste step und eine
Besonderheit wir haben ein unheimlich
geiles Schloss dass man hierüber
verriegelt und ein magnetisches Schloss
hier das automatisch eingezogen wird
sobald es hier in der Zarge ankommt
krank so geil das ist der Korpus vom
Einbauschrank ihr seht schon eine
Aussparung Aussparung ist genau hier für
den Schaltkasten damit der im Schrank
verschwindet aber trotzdem natürlich
perfekt
so zugänglich bleibt ich bin unglaublich
happy Tag 1 ist rum hier ist natürlich
noch Folie drauf die Tür ist noch nicht
gemacht aber die ersten Parts der
Einbaulösung sind drin und man kann sich
so langsam vorstellen wie es dann am
Ende wirklich aussieht wir haben einen
Kühlschrank wir haben einen Waschbecken
wir haben Ceranfeld wir haben alles drin
wir haben ein unglaublich geilen
Kleiderschrank und klar wir sind noch
nicht am Ende aber es fühlt sich an wie
ein wirklicher Endspurt dass die
Hauptsache morgen wird das Ganze hier
fertig gemacht und dann können wir
endlich die erste Nacht auf unsere Emma
Matratze schlafen Arbeitstag Nummer 6
die Jungs machen weiter mit der Küche
und wir sitzen hier im Büro machen den
Schnitt für die nächste Folge von mir
und des Dienst die am Montag kommt da
konnte ich leider nicht dabei sein
deswegen schnell zu Tag Nummer 7 für
mich ein wirklich besonderer Tag der Tag
an dem sich die gesamte Arbeit der
letzten Monate auszahlt
es ist der 11.11 in Köln das bedeutet
Karnevalsbeginn ich habe etwas probieren
mitgebracht und wir schauen mal wie weit
die Jungs sind heute ist der finale Tag
Alter
und dann war es endlich soweit
Lattenrost und Matratze konnten endlich
eingebaut werden
[Musik]
hammermäßig und genau das war der finale
Moment für heute alles ist aufgebaut die
Matratze liegt im Prinzip könnte man
jetzt hier einziehen wenn man denn nicht
aufs Klo müsste Duschen müsste oder eine
Heizung bräuchte
[Musik]
komplett krank guckt euch das mal an die
Lösung damit wir hier hinter dem Schrank
noch an den Durchlauferhitzer und an die
ganzen Technik dahinter kommen ist hier
eine perfekte Rückwand mit so einem
Gegenstoß da hinten was für ein Traum
ist dieses satisfying Ding aber im
Großformat bitte an als würde ich so
eine Liege nagelneue Wohnung auspacken
getestet
wunderbar
wirklich völlig verrückt was die Jungs
hier abgerissen haben ich bin unheimlich
happy mit dem Resultat kleiner das hier
ist der Kleiderschrank
Digger die Küche das Bett
versteckte Tür natürlich gibt es noch
eine Menge zu tun wir müssen die Fenster
noch neu machen die Fensterbänke müssen
gemacht werden die Elektrik das
Badezimmer die Haustür und noch ganz
viel mehr das hier war nicht das letzte
Video aber es fühlt sich an wie ein sehr
großer Schritt vergesst nicht den Kanal
zu abonnieren damit ihr die nächsten
Videos nicht verpasst ich denke es sind
noch zwei oder drei Videos ich will hier
noch nicht zu viel zeigen das kommt
alles noch in der roomtour aber das hier
war wirklich ein riesen Schritt in die
richtige Richtung macht's gut aus der
kleinsten berufsbude Kölns die
mittlerweile keine hochrute mehr